we are heading to new york new york
we're gonna get carson
[Music]
all right good morning actually it's
almost eleven we're supposed to leave at
six o'clock
they woke up at seven something
you woke up at what what time do you
wanna come at like 7 30 7 30 what time
did you wake up katherine i woke up at
10 00 7 50. i i well i went downstairs
at 7 30. okay anyways jeffy what time
did you wake up
eight yeah we woke up at night i woke up
at 5 45. people got 5 45 i did no
i almost got up but i was really tired
and then i went back to sleep
i woke up at night anyways we are
heading to new york
you know the sun i love you new york i
don't know the sun i don't know that
size yeah i don't know
you know the sound i'm talking about
yeah okay sing it then sing it i don't
know the lyrics though okay i know it's
like it has new york yeah anyways i'm
just making it up right now concrete
jungle west street
oh that's that's jason
no that's that's not the one that was
hanging out okay anyways we're on the
road we're going to new york it was kind
of um
uh chaotic this morning are you thinking
of that frank sinatra i don't know start
spreading no no okay no no oh my god
what kind of song is that i don't know
i'm leaving today okay can you be quiet
i want to be a part of it
new york new york
huh
i want to wake up in a city that never
says okay can you start singing because
it's going to give us copyright and fine
time
la la la la
i don't know him is that the song is
that the right song
what a great uber driver though
who which uber driver dr like drives a
course
with a believable bill
that's the next we should do a series
where i pick up people in uber and take
them
yeah that's that's true that could be a
series anyway so we're going to
new york we're on the highway right now
will take us
about eight hours
probably nine with a stop and full
bathroom breaks and stuff
you guys excited kids are very excited
wow wow wow okay anyways let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right we're leaving canada
everyone's on their phone vlogging
i'm not vlogging i'm just taking a video
that's vlogging
all right we
are officially and ends buffalo just
crossed the border
it was very smooth it was very smooth
kids did great kiss a great guy was
super nice at the border yeah
we're ready to go yep let's go
[Music]
that was a satisfy meal right okay
very satisfied two two slices of apple
mcdonald's is so generous they decided
to give me two slices of apples yeah all
right we're back on the road and let's
go new york three more hours hey we're
gonna get cars but okay
okay
we are 29 minutes 29 minutes away from
new york
new york
we're here almost
and here it is that's right let me show
manhattan
manhattan you can see my finger that's
manhattan your fingers
[Music]
evan you excited are you excited for new
york let's go let's go let's go let's go
let's go
[Music]
all right we're going to the famous new
york tunnel holland
tunnel
under the hudson river
it's there almost there
oh look at that building wow
that building oh my god that looks so
messed up
all right we have just parked our car
we're gonna leave the car in the garage
for three days and then now we're gonna
walk to our hotel and it's this guy
these guys
first time in new york yeah
[Music]
we just dropped everything off
and this is our time to take the kids
take some new york pizza let's go you
like pizza i love pizza pepperoni
belongs on pizza people pepperoni what
pepperoni
no pineapple belongs on pizza oh okay
pineapple i like pineapple
all right let's go pizza
[Music]
we're going to get some joe's pizza
delicious
[Music]
tomorrow
just trying to make it an awesome
experience for the kids
we're gonna wake up we're gonna look at
the we're gonna get some coffee probably
breakfast get the go to the raging bull
on wall street take the ferry go down to
see statue of liberty and back
uh
see a bunch of stuff around the downtown
go to chinatown work our way up to
fifth avenue rockefeller center
empire state building uh end in central
park
and we'll see if we get it all done
found some really fun places along the
way some restaurants some treats
um nina likes her food so a couple of
surprises in there oh oh you're right
you know gotta make it about the wife a
little bit too
and
yeah i think we're pretty good i think
it's a solid plan for tomorrow as long
as it doesn't rain so um
gonna have a shower
clean up
get ready
go to sleep
and crush tomorrow
if you want to see what we do tomorrow
check the video right there next to me
it's lots of fun i promise continue to
believe and we'll see you there